- Avec des dizaines de milliers
de cas positifs recensés
chaque jour, de plus en plus de
Québécois lelelement vaccinés
contractent la COVID-19.
Ces personnes ont-elles besoin
d'une dose de rappel?
Pas selon le gouvernement.
Dr HORACIO ARRUDA, directeur
national de santé publique, Qc
- Les recommandations d'experts
actuellement démontrent que
v v v vous avez reçu deux doses
d'ARN messager, Pfizer ou
Moderna, et que vous faites
la maladie, cette maladie-là
vous confirme comme si c'était
une troisième dose.
Dre CAROLINE QUACH, pédiatre,
microbiologiste-infectiologue,
- En termes d'efficacité
vaccinale, donc de protection
contre la maladie, les gens
qui ont fait l'infection et
qui ont eu deux doses de vaccin
sont ceux qui sonteueueueux
protégés pour l'instant.
- Mais le Québec fait bande
à part dans ses recommandations
Le CCNI, le Comité consultatif
national surununununisation
du Canada, suggère plutôt
le contraire aux provinces.
Pour ces scientifiques,
contracter la COVID-19 n'est pas
l'éqntntntnt d'une dose
de vaccin, un avis partagé
par certains experts québécois.
Dr ANDRÉ VEILLETTE,
immunologue, IRCM
rsrsrsrsrsonnellement, j'ai tous
été contre l'idée de compter
l'infection comme une dose
parce que je pense que l'impact
de l'infection sur la protectio.
- Les experts sont partagés,
les directives sont
loin d'être claires.
Qu'en pensent les Québécois?
Les double-vaccinés infectés
devraient-ils avoir une 3e dose?
- Je pense que c'est nécessaire
quand même pour qu'on puisse
s'en sortir.
- Je dirais : non, ça sert à
rien parce qu'on sait justemment
qu'ils contractent une certaine
immunité plus qu'il y a déjà
deux doses, donc je pense que
la troisième ne servirait
à rien.
- Chose certaine,
pour toute personne souhaitant
s s s s s supplémentaire,
y avoir accès n'est pas interdit
ou contre-indiqué, surtout
pour celle infectée
au début de la pandémie.
- Il faudrait idéalement
qu'elle soit à au moins 3 mois
depuis sa dernière dose et
donc probablement plus q
six mois depuis son infection
initiale, donc c'est sûr
que les gens qui ont fait
l'infection par exemple
en mars 2020 pourraient
considérer aller chercher
une dose de rappel sansllllllèm.
- Deux questions demeurent :
la troisième dose sera-t-elle
nécessaire pour avoir droit
au passeport vaccinal?
Et si oui, le résultat d'un test
rapide sera-t-il accepté comme
preuve de contamination?
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.